hey guys welcome back we're going to be
looking at
ogre next today i figured i'd go ahead
and cover this one because i
sort of glazed over in the last one i
was using
that's in my last tutorial the how to
ogre
the c renderer i was looking at the old
version
so the old version is just called ogre
and it's starting to get a little
outdated and it looks like the more
modern one
is over next so you can go to their web
light
web light website and just go get the
sdk
but i'm going to talk about building it
from source
and that's what this tutorial is on so
the prereqs here
first you are going to need python so go
get the latest version of python
add it to your path on the install and
you should be good there
it does need that for one of the shader
compilers that it uses
so if you look at ogre 3d we'll just
kind of glaze over do a little intro
here
you've got everything here if you go to
like the learning resources
find you find some stuff here you don't
really see anything about the 2.0
version so almost all the stuff on their
website
is uh the old one so if you go over here
you get the the old version over next
it's a new one and these are just the
sdks i believe
yeah well you can grab the source here
too but we're not gonna do that
we're not gonna mess with our website
we're just going to go straight to
github
you want to find over next on the ogre
cave
and this is a little bit more involved
but i'll walk you through everything you
need to do to get this up and running so
that you can run the demos because if
you just clone this and try to build it
it will fail
what you actually need first is the ogre
next dependencies here they are
over next depths but you do need to
clone this first and if you go look in
the source you'll see that it has a sub
module so you do
also need to grab the sub modules with
it so
see get clone with sub modules get clone
with
sub modules
basically when you clone you want to do
a
an additional command i'm not sure if
it's in here
or you can just do git sub module knit
and you just want to make sure that sdl
is is there basically
so what you do is you just uh you go to
overdepth i'll just start walking
through it now
and you copy this then we're going to
use fork
as our cloning or for github
we're going to use it to clone
everything you can use just the command
line if you want
this just makes it a little easier i've
already got it cloned here yeah i'm on
it right now
basically you just go to file clone
paste it in there make sure it's going
where you want to go it
go and and then and just clone it and
then after it's cloned you want to go to
the console
well i guess you could open up open it
up
you go open in file explorer and just go
to the source and make sure the sdl2
stuff is there
if it is not there it's going to fail so
you want to open the console
and if you get sub module
i believe it's update with
init i might be slightly wrong in that
if i am wreck me in the comments below
but basically you want to make sure it
grabs the sub modules it's really
important
and at this point you can open up your
cmake
gui and path to
ogre depths and make an out for it
i'm going with this same folder and then
i'll
make sure i spell this right here we go
then out build
and you just want to do a configure and
generate i've already done this so it's
happening like instantly
and then you want to open it up after
that
make sure you're using visual studio 16
if you want to follow
my tutorial here if you're doing
something different that's fine too
now what you want to do is look for the
install over here on the side under your
solution
explorer and you want to build the
install in both debug
so you change this up here to debug or
go to build
then you'll after this finishes this
will take a while
i've already done it so it's just going
to say up to date but i didn't have any
problems here
let it go through it looks like it's
doing something
so over next is basically their 2.0
version i don't know if i already said
that but it is the more modern one
and i think it's still considered
unstable
but it's getting you the the more modern
features
so if you're a game developer and you
want everything to be really stable you
should probably use the old version
but if you want to be on the bleeding
edge then over next is where you want to
be
this is taking a while as you can see
it's just building all the tools and
dependencies spur v
is for doing shaders and you'll see a
bunch of other stuff they got sdl stuff
probably for the windowing
so this is just all the just all these
dependencies that are going to be needed
like it's mostly shader stuff but also
there's the image stuff for
probably for texturing i'm not sure what
they do with sdl2 exactly
i'm guessing when doing it this doesn't
have sound included
and z live of course for
packaging and stuff
it looks like it did rebuild stuff some
stuff but basically you want to get to
the bottom
and make sure it has succeeded if you
see some failed you might need to
address those
and then you want to switch this to
release and just do the exact same thing
go to install and build the install you
can right click on it there and do build
it's going to take a while so i'm not
going to do it again
let's go to the next part so once you
get debug
and release built the next thing you
want to do
is clone over next and you do that from
github of course just go back to the
ogre cape find ogre next
copy the location and this one does not
have
any submodules so you don't need to
worry about that recurs thing
main thing you need to do is just make
sure you have those over next
dependencies or this won't work
so we want to clone that i've already
got it cloned but it's the same process
you go to file
clone make sure it's where you want it
to go i put it in the same directory
the way the folders are right next to
each other if i do open
explorer and go back one i'll see over
next and over next dependencies
those need to work together and there's
the old one right there so i've got them
all now
so once you get that nice and cloned
uh okay one thing that's also cool about
this i'll just mention as a sort of side
note anytime if you have these repos
like this you can open them up
anytime there's an update you can just
pull down the changes and rebuild and
get things going and hey if you happen
to notice something that you can fix
you can make a pull request live and
help them out and get you some open
source
contribution points which is always nice
all right so once you have that cloned
you basically want to go back to cmake
and now go to over next
um i'm just typing it in here but you
can always hit these browse buttons over
here
over next you can just delete the depths
basically
there and there we go so now this is a
little bit trickier
because you do have to do one critical
thing so first of all just hit configure
once
and it's going to say cannot find some
packages and it's going to fail
that is fine no we could have typed in a
custom command to make those not fail
basically what we want to do is look
through all this red stuff
actually we need to wait until it
finishes in this ogre dependencies
directory we want to
pass this to overdepths out build over
depths
but wherever you built that
looks like this one might actually
succeed yeah this will succeed for me
um but it's gonna fail if you don't have
these ogre depths here and you just need
to add them
you can just path to them with this
little button over on the side
and i've already got a path then you say
select folder and then just do it again
and it will succeed you'll see you have
some stuff disabled like use boost
disable i don't have
boost but that's it that's not that's
fine you don't have to have everything
you just have to have the core stuff
then of course you do generate
let it generate
and then you do open project and now
you're
pretty much pretty much to the home
stretch here
if you got those dependencies built in
both release and debug
this should all go pretty smooth from
here now you want to make sure you also
do an install on release and debug on
this one too
because that actually puts the sdk in
its place
if i'm understanding that correctly and
you need that
so once you have the install you just do
a build just right click and build
then you can start running these samples
so you can go down here on your solution
explorer
you'll see tutorial 0 to 6
and they actually walk through pretty
good so
for example i'm on tutorial sample four
here
if you right click and set as startup
you can click the debugger up here and
actually run it
and get some other stuff going hopefully
this doesn't crash
pop up and ask you a rendering system
i've got gl
or directx 11. i'm going to use directx
11.
let it load up and it just gives you
this little sample
and it gives you some f keys over here
as you can see
and it basically walks you through some
things and we have f1 as it says it
tells you more so there is some decent
some decent stuff in here to help you
out
and i believe you leave with escape no i
mean
okay i guess we got alt f4 out of this
you can you should be now able to run
any of these
samples and of course you can go in them
and take a look at the source
and there's not a whole lot there's just
a few source files but it should help
you get started and how to initialize
your project
and all of that now i haven't gone in
and done my own project using this yet
i've only ran the samples and got it all
set up
but it did take a little bit of uh just
careful
reading and a lot of googling to to
figure all this out and make sure i had
the dependencies right
so that's why i'm making a video on it
it's not exactly straightforward
um there is a guide here this is the
last thing i'll show you and i'll leave
it off
here this is over at
this website here now this wasn't easy
to find a google search did not find
this i don't remember how i found this
page but eventually i just found
it it really was not up there anywhere
but it does have some some 2.2 stuff
like if you do google you find all the
1.112
the old version stuff so i thought it
would be important to make a video in
case anyone's trying to use ogre next
and wants to build it from source and
get it all figured out
this is how you do it now this
documentation is a little outdated as
you can see they're using
i don't know what they're using but this
is like an older looking window
maybe from windows 7 it maybe even looks
like
and our cmake is 2.8 so yeah this is
definitely pretty outdated documentation
but it does generally walk you through
how to get it set up and installed
and tells you about that dependencies
thing i talked about so that's kind of
how i figure that out
but the if you go further here there
aren't really any good tutorials
in here or anything you basically just
gotta go off those samples
and start playing around with it and
figure it out that way
so that's it hope you guys have some
success in getting this all going up
going i'm gonna look at maybe one more
of these as an outro
but i would recommend just going through
these one by one and reading everything
it tells you
about because it tells you how to like
multi-thread
your uh physics and stuff if you have
physics added so that way it doesn't
hiccup too much if you're actually using
it in a game i'm going to switch to this
one here this one looks like it might be
cool the sky tutorial post process
let's have a look at what it it looks
like here
we use directx 11. there we go and we
can actually look around with the
mouse this is pretty cool can i walk
around no but it looks like i can use my
mouse to move the
this little block around
so that's pretty cool
all right and there's all sorts of stuff
looks like you do have to
alt i don't see another way to quit i
just have to alt f4 out of these
there might be another way there's a
bunch of other samples in there if if
they have errors and don't run
you might have done the dependencies
wrong so just go double check everything
maybe go redo it follow these steps
carefully
all right see you guys in the next video
peace out